this is a production of Cornell
University
[Applause]
I'd like to start out by introducing the
people in my group that are actively
have actually been working with health
diseases I'll tell you what I think
about when diseases but I'd like to
first of all Jamie Cummings is here to
admit with with life program for a
number of years it's now with the IPM
program what kind of got us started on
some of our network Kevin you raise your
hand there Kevin Myers and and now
gemstar is my research and extension
support that specialists so what I'd
really like you to know is when you're
out in your hemp fields and you're
finding things you think may be diseases
if you notice something say something
let us know get in contact with one of
us and we'd like to diagnose the problem
like any other new crop there are paths
insects weeds diseases that will be
a problem in the production of that crop
and of course this is the second year
out with this new crop in New York State
unless you go way back and it might have
been grown previously but in recent
history it's it's all new to us and that
includes the plant pathologists that are
working on this so with our one care of
experience last year under our belt we
saw a dozen different microbial
organisms that we found that cause
disease on em and these vary everything
from things that cause of rotting and
the root system that affect a seedling
establishment on the ground to things
that cause a lot of fungi they caused
spots on leaves lighting on leaves and
then we saw things also in the in the
bucks and the hats the flower parts and
sees very often we found something we
would call rain mole Petridis a fumble
investing the buzz but why alert are the
messages that most of the industrial
government we've seen has been pretty
damn healthy as you may know and you're
gonna hear more about today there are
different classes and uses of industrial
hemp from the CBD pipes this is a drain
pipes to the to the fiber pipes etc
you're gonna hear about that so there's
a lot of different genetics out there in
these fields and I'm sure delivery and
others are going to talk about that but
that means there's a lot of diversity in
the crop that brings about the
corresponding diversity and the microbes
that cause disease so we definitely seen
in some of the CBD pipes or of
susceptibility to some of the leaf spot
pathogens for instance so I'm not going
to try to clutter your minds with a lot
of Latin names of microbes today but
again what I'd like to leave you knowing
is that we're we're trying to get an
early handle on these things eventually
what we'd like to see
to try to fix election and these
different classes where he's doing
reading and see if we can't increase the
level of natural genetic disease
resistance which would be our first line
of defense I think you're all aware you
will hear from others here today that
because of its its status as a
non-profit elite at this point there
there are amount of the fifth row
labeled materials or control pests and
that includes diseases even things like
seat treatments that outlets going to
talk a little bit more about but
eventually we hope as the classification
of this tropical slaw from the federal
government they've got to keep up with
what's not at the state level that we
will be starting to look at different
kinds of nuts management materials
including synthetic chemicals is what
well
and a group of group materials organic
production right now the best thing we
can do is is start out with some sound
cultural practices and I think you'll
hear this over and over again today
rotation is the greatest friend there's
less likely to be disease in fact if you
grow in the sequence fairly unrelated
crops so emptying a broad leaf
probably it's best rotational crop
partners would be things like small
grain cereals and corn
the grasses of monocots we have some
commonality in some of the pests
especially across other broadleaf crops
we're going to learn more about that as
we go but one of the biggest problems we
have is white mole than anybody that
grow soybeans or vegetables is well
acquainted with and so a rotation with
white beans or some of the more
susceptible vegetable crops is probably
not not the greatest choice because of
the susceptibility
at all and we're learning other
connections like that a lot of the
disease organisms some of the couple
leaves month are very specific for a
particular species of plant and so it's
not so much of a problem therefore
additional sequence and perhaps looking
at variation in the bride's and both of
ours
of the double that some are going to be
more susceptible develop itself as they
go along and working with Larry this
program I think they're underwater
more about cytosol again my message to
you here today is if you see something
that appears that might be disease worth
the business of diagnosing that it's
trying to get a handle on what luck they
work with it so thank you requested your
learning presence for Garrett
[Music]
okay so we have we have a laboratory is
depakote and I know you've got maybe we
put that under weapon
that might be the easiest thing as we've
is what the diagnosis of plant diseases
we can put that on the website
otherwise why why email you see b3 at
Cornell dot edu but look I think that
or he'll have website competitive baqara
2 today
yes sir
you know the question here is we have a
listing of varieties and by diseases of
our relatives susceptibilities and quite
honestly we're so thoroughly into that
cycle of trying to understand that that
we kind of have a shopping list the
things we have seen but the partition
about that finally we're not there
either
and of course this is a very dry form
shortly part of the growing season we'll
see how that ends up but there up to
this point and the growing seasons there
has not been an intense these diseases
we have very hard to find any at all so
good offense but last year we can't walk
22 different pathogens as far as which
ones we're going
severe that still is where there's not
really an extensive swollen
so we're very much a narrative learning
over here
I think this thing is hot
so question presents a good ones about
that we excused any kind of exhibitors
natural products whatever their soil by
home itself the short answer is no I
think there's a lot of possibilities
there but with the learning curve we're
we're here somewhere
both are some of our aspirations as we
move the walk with us and I might point
out it is I'm sure Larry will that we're
not in this by ourselves there are 35
other states with EF so the question was
referring to connecting with State
Department of Environmental Conservation
which
there are any of these disease control
materials so even before it got the
state regulatory book there's nothing
allowed now there are some things that
are on the grass lipstick are used or
maybe he'll talk
that but there are some materials that
might be useful in certain things but in
general we don't really have any tool
or disease or insect all different
okay maybe we talk about that whole
label - thank you
[Music]
if anybody just raise your hand if you
smell like they have a
so my face here at the instrument
station
used to say that right now is repenting
of the New York State extra recitation
for the past
right there so here
by my areas exceed Science and
Technology so I my nature of my program
but also my health
[Music]
crops especially
and
there's really what if it
where there's many see challenges and it
is really a new crop this is Jerry
talked about in his presentation some
things we kind of respect there's
something
ever work that you can touch up somebody
else work really
so we're really trying to establish some
roads now science that science that
can be translated into outrage of
extension to veterinary or edible
community it's the kind of product we
get here if we look at the 24:15
department bill and allow the space to
go ahead and
research might startle states have done
this newer competitiveness and a big way
last year an even bigger weight this
year
I contacted Andean market we're looking
at 30
there's a temple Atlanta tea are wrong
here in New York State this side of the
Mississippi
major states Kentucky North Carolina and
then you go to the mountain state of
Colorado the largest in Oregon and the
west coast so services of substantial
industry yeah we also learned a lot from
other countries in particular our
neighbors to the north Canada has over
110,000 acres of more mature canary
they're very can rely on four seed
companies for getting my materials as
far as seed sources so in your picture
probably already been growing you can't
we know what the seats look like if you
actually put a seed on top of the park
just about the actual size of the seat
this is just one of the commercial life
that was used to death of it last
and some of the harbor primer trials
home angel and we did not adulterate the
part of their on the left this is this a
huge range of sizes and if you working
with any of the trucks if you work with
the bill crops and vegetable products
you know the same company
much better job of sorting seats by size
so that's kind of the first thing is is
it reveal if you break their shape see
we've done not working those small
secret really just produce run plants
are really just really kind of just bear
part of seat count but they do
and it started out with those losses my
goal and working in the areas with this
program is we're trying to be proactive
and looking at C treatments for the
future in 2018 marvelous to look at that
one it all goes well and should be
exempted of the DBA which is really
going to open up on floodgate we're
having kids being drawn just as in any
of their vegetables or feels rough so
there were also of pesticides
we're trying to be proactive instead of
looking ahead though it's been working
the best more special economic scenario
it was a higher more higher one works
with university partners and others the
registration of the turtles both
chemical and biological organism and so
higher worry
there's a foreground now at NC State
I mean weed control and so we're kind of
trying to get our foot in the door for
the next year for 2019
so the so one part of that is decided by
chemical or pesticide is how we gonna
fight it so my laboratory does a lot
better so these are kind of a story that
can definitely bring them
yeah we're getting to the tariff on the
speed the power would you see a lot of
uniformity
so if transmitted some time of upgrading
the c-section okay so now we can see
whether the property has a difference
we could get a very uniform
[Music]
again kind of working to try to
establish ourselves with a higher war
work with that
many years again looking at chemicals a
treatments for diseases but also to like
as mild pesticides would you be organic
material so that's kind of a next year's
presentation so I got suspended looking
at
we're going to change ears accountancy
testing see quality has been
standardized testing procedures are in
place they've been in place Romania
other products ain't using a ball
contest
we're looking at two samples of
amphitheater for example with 23 C
models that are being used with steel
coils this year and my laboratory did
about the germination and the purity of
the level very poor germination lack of
uniformity and the farmer turned out
pretty well but this is no la mole from
things like that so there can't be
actually internal as well warning
pathogens oflife diseases within disease
and there's been a kind of a need for
having effective secret in control there
what we'd like to do is have the looks
like revolt health on the right hand
side with very good a warm seat Lee
termination potential okay so let's go
over to the second page of that
and there are RNA oscillation
for the US Ernie has minimal sandwich
standards for what the few months
termination
middle of donations
other aspects of security
so inert material broken see other
other proxies can be present we see any
of those would distress from having
purity so and there are already
thresholds down with them so what we're
looking at here are those 23 siva hi
Frank those high to low germination and
you can see work on both the board as
far as determination to percentages
those determinations again using 80% of
the threshold percent sea level would
even have certification status to these
planet diseases now I have a few other
areas over here that are highlighted in
red on the purity side so again the
other prophecies exceeds the
certification standards other other
wheat seeds own presence so if we just
took these p5 destructors
we'd only have a little over 40% of the
cidade could even pass so this industry
which is somewhat benefit
raise itself up just to put itself to
help to make certification standards so
that's kind of like
here is the equality can be good look at
this time a 34c and if you have other
prophecies in our material we see that
when you open up that factor see there
there that is really something to see
companies can easily clean out with see
conditioning equipment so we really need
to have really improved speed line to
really improve and Estelle
so this type of is it opens up anybody
else question and accomplish your
purposes because some of you are CPD
people this these all these varieties
are for fiber or per frame we've not
done that we have that CBD right
but I just want to talk another big job
yes sir you have a
okay so basically what are our standards
that we use so there is official
standards for seat testing adopted by a
company let's say
associate efficiency they'll it's the
same technical criteria as our safety
laboratory would use in Albany as well
as other states so there are criteria as
far as that's the journalist receiver
does the duration of the tough things
like that so we're really four five
right in prescribed methods that were
following is Marit of what these
determinations and the period of Death
Star are chemicals
we work
basically there
[Music]
Marcus
particularly because that was asking
about irrelevant
about what what seek treatment so Islam
and
when I would call in today does
we may have or next season as early as I
see some very optimistic that we have
some of these in appear houses already
used by the field club so be more of a
steep treatment rather than don't think
of like a Steve melon and things like
that we're really just look
small aperture
the organic grower
you to those where they where the
chemical type secret which would be just
for our conventional cyclo production
just the way it is in prophecy but again
it's the time we got to hit the 2018
marvelous but I have
where campus exempted that will open
things up so again what Gary and I are
trying to strategize is try to be
proactive Pentagon
this year what is 10 the night seed and
how are they doing it like networking
right for those of you involved in CPD
production there
you have an option and depends on what
the seed companies define it as
feminized seeds
what are feminized seeds basically is
you want to have the plants that you're
producing only to produce a flower
you should not want to help those
produce male flowers hemp seeds are
naturally what we told iishe this means
they have there's there's male plants
and female plants what we want they're
just the flower production where the
secret these productions be the highest
is those that only produce female
flowers so as they progress
so what a feminized seat part of that is
is a particular method that needs to be
done during the steep production to
produce those feminized seeds
where are you using different materials
silver material things like they have to
change the sex expression so basically
think of it our own kind of our
chromosomes with xx and XY campus is is
the same type of a plant species with XX
being female XY being male so basically
is you need to have XX knowledge to
produce the seeds to produce the
feminized seeds oh it's a rather
specialized the companies that these
seeds are extremely expensive those of
you working in it maybe a dollar or so
per seat so it's an expensive type of
but one that you would have that high
level of very very high level of female
plants the other way is is if you do not
have that or if this procedure is during
seed production still issue some males
those males are really going to have to
be broke out during the C production
time during the crop production time so
you do not have that source yeah Larry
you wanted to jump in here move on okay
oh yeah I just want to say that some of
the grant funding that we happen to be
overstating facilitate certified seed
production seats are a big issue because
federally still considers it illegal to
move live seat across state lines so
that was a strong disincentive for
to invest to see production when it is
definitely illegal without the cell
across state lines
now the Omnibus spending act included
language that said that the federal
government have not extended any funds
to intercept that movement but the TGA
still considers it illegal so when
companies are doing their due diligence
their lawyers tell them so it has been a
challenge for us to see companies that
overcome that barrier but he also said
that New York State is not necessarily
the best environment so when those
restrictions are lifted we may well see
an intensification of C production in
those states at that optimum Playa
Tori's disease
so it's another disincentive for New
York seed companies to produce material
all that being said we were we had a
company committed to producing certified
seed here Indigo state covers
International hoc solutions was
committed to produce surf club seat of
yellow chassis one of our best health
department and last year unfortunately
it took us any more than eight weeks to
get that
[Music]
took us human Annette months to get to
see important the first and sanitary
certificate a second time he's coming
right there up the computers multi so
that seat is now sitting in our freezer
here and the vertebral here so next year
we should have certified
[Music]
so so the question is are there
companies that are producing seed in
your state no there are no companies
right now producing seeds within New
York State near say Agra markets has
adopted the chaos certification
standards
certified 86 so we now have more time
for surprises even putting a label on MC
by next year we will have surprises
required
there is another report to do surprising
Oh
all
so at Cornell University we do not work
on marijuana so no we're not medical
marijuana
I'm gonna back it up to six weenies and
answer some of your questions and give
and hope you
my name is
how many secretary I see how many here
are not currently involved in the
program
so
I don't think I need to run through the
entire process as y'all are talking
afterward water views just too great
synopsis right now as I mentioned
previously we have about 3,200 acres
could be planted in New York state
approves the planting if everyone
doesn't approve planted to them to the
extent that they apply
because this is a research project we
have a lot of CPP applications come in
in the past in the first few years this
year particularly so we have stopped
taking CBD applications to allow us to
get a handle on the CBD world and to
better that is establish guidelines for
or regulating CBD we are as I said we
are still taking applications for
growers however given the lateness of
the season it would probably be a viable
the wait until later applied because it
is a three-year purpose so he wouldn't
want to waste her to birthing and not be
able to anything
this year with regard to getting to see
as many of you might know if you want to
get seats from the internet and source
you have to come to us we hold the DJ
import permit you would submit your
request through wise you make all these
arrangements with your seed company just
a minute request a la sweeden file the
dv8 paperwork they send us the import
permits you then get them to do to the
seat company and your seat has to come
to always we'd have to take possession
of it you have to come pick it up in
Albany we try to get around this we ask
that you allow us to be serviced at
farms and we got a pinko so that just is
the way it is for now as also as
mentioned earlier there is pending
couple legislation federal farm bill if
the particle passes that this is a big
unit with the language that's included
in the Senate version this program is
likely to change quite a bit and that we
may not be required to make you submit a
research question to us it would take it
out of the realm of research it would
treat it more like a regular
agricultural crop however you would
still have to come through us
we will still be regulated in fact that
the law passes as written we will have
to submit our program to the federal
government for their approval and then
we would be run through the guidelines
that are approved by the federal level
so there are still some changes to be
made in the future we think with regard
to how the program is wrought perhaps it
will require less on your part with
regard to coming up in the research over
it but it will still be regulated you
still likely have to come out on the
test to ensure that the THC levels are
but they the definition of industrial
health so having said all that I know
usually whatever I have one of these
events there's lots of questions that
could take a lots of times I don't want
to bore you with more stuff about the
process and just a feeling
[Music]
and the question is is there a fixed
rate from CPD licenses right now that is
not a fixed rate we have just not been
able to take decision was made that
we're not going to take any more of the
diabetes
we expect that sometime in the future
that we will forget did you see do you
have what diction to get power no
there's not sure what us will be we
don't we don't know
I have I don't think it would be years
but
you know about
No
I do not know the rule but this is this
is in part the question is do I know the
regulations with regard to shipping CPT
office over state lines in teacher form
or other like that this is where some of
the issues lies with with regard to CPT
production and the question of legality
and we always advise people that they
need to get a good lawyer lawyer network
on campus issues this environment is
changing rapidly the DJ I'm sorry the
FDA recently approved alcohol have a
dialect for the treatment of seizures in
epileptic children and CBT is a major
component of that which says now which
now means that CBD perhaps will be
looked at differently by the federal
government so we need to we need to see
what the proper to do with the power
regulation CBD
the processing grant algorithm is run
through Empire State Development it's a
different agency I do know that they
they did stop taking the allocations for
the faculty I'm not sure whether that
will open up but I think once again it
was because many of those applications
were related to CBD I think you think of
a better handle on TV we haven't yet got
a it's a would be out of 32 hundred or
so and we're not yet sure how many look
at it we're seeing the process of having
our horticulture inspectors go out to
ground truth what actually was to land
it and of course he'll be back up at
harvest time to take the samples that
you will be tested
[Music]
and
falling power
[Music]
I don't I don't know off the top of my
head to basket or disappear
[Music]
that's an excellent question last thing
is how do they sell CBD flowers in a
sort of Geneva that is not within our
program that's not within our purview
and that is a function of lack of
clarity with regard to the CBD a lack of
branches
the question was that I talk more about
how the state program will take that the
farm bill passes it will require that we
will submit our program to the federal
government for their approval
it would also receive either side would
take a hospital have out of the world
control substance we predicted that's
highly regulated federal side but it
would they would still require us to do
sampling testing to ensure that the THC
levels work forward as a definition and
there were there was no longer States
invisibly they would no longer be a
requirement than to be a research
project and the restrictions with regard
to commercialization with no longer be
there some of it right now through
commercialization important to pedal is
allowed potato
that's what I understand yeah we just
don't have that handle on it because we
would still have to go where everything
is growing and we need to sample it
that's okay the question is are the
research license renewable right that's
the research authorization it's good for
three years it's a $500 a permit to you
and then if your research project is not
completed at the end of the three years
you can apply to us birth extension we
haven't yet have that happen because we
haven't have this is a guest
[Music]
the question is that the $500 fee
remains is saying that the department
has I don't know
if the question is if the part milk is
not that's what we see is what we're
doing now I don't think so I think that
we are pretty well on the road could be
an exhaustive Penn State I believe that
we would continue to work under the
curve
that's a tough question it would be
might ever be my best guess let's assume
there would be a continuation of the
existing in marijuana
question is if marijuana is legalized in
the state now without the programs would
be two very distinct and discrete
operations there it has been workgroup
warm by the governor's office to address
the development of an adult use
marijuana program we're not sure where
there might be overlap there may be some
in the CBD world we don't we don't know
that that I think that workgroup today
we first
so very much in the formative stages
[Music]
the question is are we still checking
THC level of the profits being wrong for
the for fiber grant yes we are because
the potential is there that a good go
hot and you wouldn't
[Music]
it would be wrong next year for the 2020
the only the only see the question is if
the seat was purchased in New York State
would still have to be picked up in our
office and all day the only time that
anyone needs to come to get to their
seat and all that is if it's even been
imported from another country pursuant
to our DEA import permit and that's
going to exact
that's because there is some gray area
with regard to federal law and various
what would enforce when authorities that
can make me the locked away on a trip
from Colorado Illinois Karissa
there is no prisoner so when I mentioned
that it is illegal to move across state
lines but that federal agencies could
not expend money to intercept death that
does not preclude the local law
enforcement agencies
yeah well I've been ignoring the side
this is an area
the question is if you're growing your
CPD and you've done your extraction
problem well you've drawn their CBD from
the sample by our inspectors and testify
our lab and it's within the 0.3%
but then through the extraction process
you can come out with a product that is
above 0.3% is that something that needs
to be destroyed or and be diluted that
is an excellent question and there's
something that we are still trying to
get a handle on and it is part of the
reason why we were no longer at this
point making the CBD application because
it you know if it's about point 3 THC
you're not within the parameters of the
industrial hemp over there so I think
well Vermont may be at 1% but they might
go on road you know we aren't where we
are compelled to the stick that
established by the federal law and state
law passed and so there are other states
that are taking a different approach but
you know we're here you have to do
the question is do I know how many acres
out of the 3200 are dedicated to CBD I
don't know the number of acres but I
know that out of the first 100
applications we've got this growing
season 50 of the more CBD so it's 50% at
that time we'd have been you know taking
fortify recommendations continuously
funded it's a it's a high percentage
that are receiving
whether taxing or financial aspect
channel me
right the question is is there a tax
taxation element to the growing or the
proofing of the CBD products or any of
these duster level and melter is that we
do not have any anything like that in
our agencies you know were strictly the
exercise a Bigfoot there are not one
special tax programs associated
based on
same whole
so the question is about as from a
grower perspective I tend to optimize
direction of CBD
while maintaining legal limits on the
THC so that's an excellent question
stress and induce that pathway we don't
have a lot of experience here at Cornell
and studying that but we do have two
trials now underway to start to quantify
CBD and THC production across a range of
different parts
this month we'll be talking about that
and then also developmental stage is
purple crossdress canoes
so all of these things are critical
questions to address and all of these
require quick turnaround the test pit
box which we also do not have any other
state so there is a regulatory testing
that will be done in food lab at Agra
markets but many of you always want
we're gonna turn around tests for THC in
the middle of the season so you can
judge when you should service so that
you don't go out so there is a urgent
intercept one more question for
attendance and that question is are you
accepting applications for affiliated
growers or CBD production from existing
license or no
so existing CBD license holders did not
expand Christmas
okay I just want to thank him again this
has been an incredible partnership and
collaboration with active markets and
the legislature maggot Marcus has never
turned down a request that I hope to
comment speak to a public group like
this they have been very open in working
with us wanting to develop a program
based on science which I
we're grateful
Thanks
[Applause]
so a lot of those questions that folks
were asking are very challenging in our
current legal landscape I serve on the
industrial hemp working group remain by
the commissioner of agriculture my farm
partner who's here also serves them
other folks here on the working group
but when the governor accepted the
report from the commissioner of health
for proposing adult abuse marijuana here
and
decriminalization of marijuana that
proposed particular challenges or the
industrial hemp industry right so if
you're growing for CBD in particular if
your plants go up they're considered
marijuana so perhaps we'll be better off
if your CBD producer getting the
marijuana grower twice but we don't know
what that program will look like whether
we will have outdoor marijuana
production and whether how that will
interact with our existing medical
marijuana program so those are very
challenging questions and again the
state has been very prudent and rolling
out these programs and I
believe that they're doing it against
ice with putting the brakes on the CP
direction right now until we can work
out the gold standard for regulation
here at the opposition so we're going to
move on
Jamie Crawford from selling fine this
program is going to talk about our
cohort trials and
so we had our trials well last year we
have the second
hopefully it's level again that finances
if any of you folks are growing
varieties that you don't have even on
this list these let us know because I
would be really interested to know if
there are green or fiber varieties in
New York this year that we haven't been
tested it would be really interesting
so from these lists you can see we've
got varieties from Canada from Serbia
from Ukraine from Italy from Poland all
those up from Oregon these developed
countries are pretty interesting when
the market started to expand there was
sort of a variety grabbed European
varieties so United States companies
have that line of exclusive rights to a
lot here began types so one thing that
we do have in our trials is high
so we have a say father the viagra that
we purchased last year that we saved the
seed from and that was produced in
Poland and
we have tiger that was producing
Kentucky's last growing zuman's we're
going to have those to do next to each
other and are we really interesting to
see what the differences are in any just
because of where the seed was grown so
we divided all of our trees up into
three trials this year we have a fiber
trial that's pretty straightforward
but then we have a grain cultivar trial
and what we're calling dual purpose and
those were those are divided by time to
maturity so based on the information
given to us from the seed companies and
anything that was a hundred and ten days
to maturity or less went into the grain
trial and then more than ten days way to
the dual purpose trials I'm so sad that
you guys aren't able to see the variety
trials because I think that really
highlights the importance of regional
testing for the varieties because we
have two varieties in our grain trial
that are not flowering yet everything
else is about knee height and starting
to seventies and those two guys are
still not flowering and then in our new
purpose trial we have three or four
varieties
that are also starting to set these well
the revenue and that was all just based
on information given to enter from the
seed company so yeah so that's a
highlight to have a part at the regional
testing is so this year we've got six
different locations there are trials so
the front you guys can see the back
[Music]
some of the trial in one Island this
year so we'll have submitted for me for
that or also have two locations here in
Geneva 1 and if the guff and then one on
artwork and the Creepo Park so for all
the organic growers of America provides
information about atmosphere and then
the last trial at the Chaney's so just
about as far north as you can get and
still be in New York State so that'll be
a totally some good information to
people that we've worked with again and
I have pulled us two varieties that are
eight feet tall in Canada for about my
three feet tall here so maybe we'll get
a little bit more height in our shady
trial and we do here or in locations so
our first try with planted last year
what and we planted it to ignite - that
was our first trial last year I it was
exceptional it was an exceptional
planting this year everything that we
planted wasn't within two weeks of that
eight but
the establishment wasn't it episode I
mean you guys know right it was right we
had a riot
and after I early July here and we went
and we took notes and because this
comparing this year's in it to last
year's we had its to peace in difficult
trial is planted in the field directly
next door to the [ __ ] planted last
year so everything should be the same
with 94 days later
but the height on advocacy that tryouts
to be shorter than air at that last year
and that's because we can't have the
rain that we had last year so if the
first month so the first four weeks
after planting we have less than two
inches and
and last year we had closer to 5 inches
so it was a really taking so I brought I
brought the plant so this is a plant
from our fiber child last year and it
was actually taller you can see the top
of it broke off we're not going to get
fiber yield like that this year it's
just not going to happen because
everything is so much shorter I have I
have a competent cigar rhenium it will
be very good some pots filled in nicely
but our fiber because of the drought is
going to be right now the plants are
about as tall as me but I know they and
they're starting to flower
so there's they're not going to get to
be like this
yeah so
when one thing I'd like to mention is is
the seat cost so we're testing 32
varieties and some of them cost just
under $3 the problems when you include
shipping these and some of them are over
$30 a pound when you include shipping
fees so when we're just buying enough
for our trials that may not be able to
be killed but I'm sure what you folks
are planting
many many acres of itself that would add
up really quickly so I know there's
people doing economic analysis of that
as well we hope to provide that to you
all as well as you can see like maybe
you get a little bit of video both with
something that you're paying $32 a pound
for but if it's not if you're not
getting the deal you know if it doesn't
make up that initial seed cost would be
very important
you harvest is coming so we don't have
an amazing information about that for
this
[Music]
so we are reporting the maturity at
different times throughout the year so
we should be able to report on watering
times for each of the different
varieties so what are the things that
what we are going as differences and put
in our trials and problems and the
company information so we know we don't
have that from one year to the next
but we do have that for this care
and the flowering time because we're
covering almost 2 degrees latitude with
flowering times making different as long
no it didn't stop but so from that point
on it's just the flowering at six roses
so
the part that would snap off easily and
would not be really useful for the fiber
[Music]
we Marvis
the treasures
ready
his question was have we done any
reading Giles we attempted to read some
of our material and if it fell last year
then if it's a learning process
I'll say we did take stands out of each
plot and we love humidity things in the
greenhouse to saw the plastic guides so
we kept trying to get a tooth threat
that way so we do have some of that
information just on a few stems from
each one but the field readiness is I
think it's a part so this year for our
fiber trials we're working with dr. Jeff
Nelson at SUNY New Paltz together with
Jennifer Jenkins at Moscow State College
so together the three of us define
reading protocols that we're going to
use for our fiber trials so we will feel
threatened all of our fiber this year
the German a weight of straw which we
didn't do last year for each block and
then shared some of that material with
Jared
everything's happy to share on the last
year we made all of our Florida rose to
a gentleman who actually has his own pit
and so heat water retinic and he sent us
some of the information that you see but
I think it was her Snickers kind of
trying to
it's on our website but we think he
asked if we had published our great
deals from last year it's not in a
peer-reviewed publication yet most of
those chronometers require two years of
data to publish it
so I believe we're waiting take up this
year's data but but we do have people
certainly event progress so you can see
the ranges of the different locations
based on income plan - if it's not bad
or I'd be happy to email it to you
directly from last year there was huge
variation depending on location like
some locations are just like around 600
[Music]
pounds per acre for the yield so pretty
close those were things that poor
establishment pressure I mean it's quite
a range across different places
[Music]
maybe's the one who acquires all of our
seaports that is a real challenge our
plantings went in probably 10 days later
than we would have liked again because
we're waiting here waiting for five
received comfortability so that has been
a real challenge my number one piece of
advice for all of you here is ordered
your seed early light and evident by
February even from cannabis kenan stone
is here from you sees the delays in
getting seed canada into the u.s. seemed
to be even worse this year supported
receiver
so match our [ __ ] from Nelson shield
this group is going to talk about some
of the sampling he's been done doing
work in sickness
[Music]
it's not here actually today going on
but I've been working this surveyed the
insect monster out the industrial Han
fields so I think the best way to show
you got this brochure here so if you
don't have one there's a couple more so
basically this whole summer without your
doing
it's going out to various farms up in
ten different counties so far this
season too sweet for insects and kinda
get an idea of what's actually out there
in the fields what may be a issue for
cars so on the sunnier three panel T or
you'll see there's three different
insect nuts
I highly the first of the left with
March plant book and that is by far the
highest conformation
and so there's a little bit of
information that I want a tool on
recording
the Phoenix tiles but if you want to
learn more about leviton hair and then
on the center panel here we have here
I've only seen this and watch our
culture how election and that was down
in Orange County and that was the most
devastating second scene so far it only
went out for two less but it took the
weapon board into this
resulting death attire
so that girl rabbit they got those two
CBD girls
so as you can see and as Gary was
talking about earlier
does he isn't it sexy to be like a
working working document basically so
the part I've seen something take a
picture or like that feel free to send
them a lot to me my email is on this
burner or just like that
so that's how we heard about the
European Court order and also we got
flea beetles which seem to be in very
high population as well that's the far
far right panel and
and the flea beetle is basically a
vegetative Peter stay with the bees
it was minimal kind of feeding size
and so not necessarily something that's
going to be harming here your deal in
the long run to put something to keep an
eye on very beautiful and I know that's
under fold in here if you have a
Japanese beetle so if you're a grower
volunteer which if you are out here you
know we have a lot of Japanese beetles
in this area so the good news is I have
plants but that one example below is an
example of what they have to do so it
may be something that you could buy for
the future three years of growing and
you see a high Japanese beetle
population travels are other ways to
combat this this whole project has been
based on an insect path so insects that
are actually in particle web but I've
been seeing a lot of natural predators
about which is a good sign so if we're
seeing these these high levels of nuts
and it's also featured it's the high
number of private degrees that means
that they're actually
good sense of file control in these
countries so as we all know there's
nothing listed for your spray-on heaven
as of right now and it's going to be a
continuing process of planning what's
out there so we're at the mercy of your
help
just methods and helpful proactive is
just sort of
yeah so the question is what steps have
you taken to assure that your trying to
help reduce these tax levels and just
overall agricultural practices
controlling weeds keeping weeds low
because a lot of
that attracts other paths that are going
to be attracted to area natural rotation
is a big one so if you're drawing the
same field
you're going to want to switch it out
because then you're going to have the
same population not say so from the park
last one
okay
yeah so the slugs and snails are a
little interesting themselves but it's
not
inside every but I haven't seen in the
audio when at UCL one thing that I have
seen from the barber stuff in op 2 is
diatomaceous period so that's a material
that you can use to base it as America
when the slugs and ears and so that's
not necessarily a chemical based control
yes
I'm sorry disease okay so that's that's
a big question
so these don't have a lot of natural
predators the ones that I've
specifically highlighted here the more
of the things that which makes that's
why I'm not seeing them at high
populations because of the natural
predators would be things like drips
deep it's more of the soft bodied
insects so these predators where it is
will inject their killed on the inside
it's kind of like a parasite there's a
toilet and then also it's feeding off of
the insects themselves so the Japanese
people as many of you know
pretty as a part exoskeleton it doesn't
have many many natural predators and so
with these kinds of things and I think
the long term goal is your operation
controlling whether in terms of
pesticides worked their other pilot or
controls again pretty
never seen any more or less issues
so the greenhouse production is
interesting I have I've only seen two
different trials I've been made for
greenhouse and a lot of clients actually
majority applies are just attracted to
the planet so they're not necessarily
following family just repeating all the
leads but they're they're a nuisance in
the sense of China
yeah so the fungus gnats are actually I
haven't seen
it's just because meet the one green
house I was it was a speed house
transplant house basically it's their
party of officers outside but the focus
that is something to keep in mind
especially with consistent wanting the
skill
so I actually have only seen one one
case of spider bites which is pretty
good but it has as you all know we're
kind of getting into the season where
everything's flowering and problems a
work done in Colorado in the West you
see a high percentage of the spider
bites coming after flower and especially
in flowers
so something that
[Applause]
that is an internal extension at Cornell
another graduate I just want to take
this opportunity because of that skies
with seasoned meat to mention that we
have a number of our CCP tag team
specialists here and maybe they could
stand up
so Mike hunter giving you a meal like
standard Eric over Janice technique
and John John can chart we made copies
of general and sharks Oh a journey late
so it's been tremendous working with all
these folks and when you have problems
they are can be your first line of
defense so by all means get their carts
at their regional locations so they
okay so I'm going to talk about an
experiment that we're taking on and to
try to address one of the I think one of
the important issues that faces and
cultivation especially as we move
towards an adult use marijuana program
if that's going to be outdoor experience
so they Williams at the University of
Kentucky who is one of our primary
academic researchers in
country shirt would be this unpublished
data that highlights their issue that is
if you are going for CVD production
there is a choose 2 3 fold decrease in
CBD concentration and the flower shoes
when the female flower to come holiday
so that is your profits Ritter in a way
when your female plants are female
plants are falling it seems to be even
worse on some of the lower
the question is except the same with THC
yes essentially the entire pathway and
I'm not sure whether it's because the
decrease in the director of the
trikonasana fish's work down regulation
of the enzymes
the bottom line is you want to maintain
in a horticultural crawl stepping
email plans on politics that's a key
question that I think that we're facing
this is a question for migrating
progress is whether we continue on in
this horticultural City and wide spacing
from transplants female plants planted
with
Oh
so I have one grower tell me to give us
$20,000 of acres investments and seeds
and labor that actually can be cut so
artistic nose plant by hand and drying
them will add up for the fall into
the alternative is a more agricultural
system in tight spaces allowing those
plans to get pollinated perhaps
capturing a great meal in addition to a
seed to be healed mechanically harvested
a drug that the seal turn and I think we
could breathe for both of ours that
produces even higher of CVD so last year
future of 75 one part annual purpose
greatest vital part of elephant turtle
workers because it produced 2% CBE while
also producing a reasonable brain so I
think this
fundamental cultivation issues that
growers will address we hope to reach
Barb's
the Duster all have denominated they
come up and talk about some of the fees
that he's seen in deal so far this year
but those bees that are attracted to
male flowers are not attracted to the
female
there's no that the production the wind
is very the parlament very light and dry
so to terrify the winds
in the Midwest where there is a lot of
ditch week Darrell Hammond throwing
around in Iowa Illinois Nebraska so
ethanol can be more than 30% of the
Monastrell in late summer
so it is a major issue fortunately we do
not have very much left in New York
State we collect it from one girl
population in Fort Wayne I've heard
about a couple of others that will
investigate here in the next month but
we have very little there
so that is not a major concern you know
state the major concern would be if your
neighbor across the street class a grain
of fiber creels Livonia certain items
right this one a lot of pollen
you're directly downwind
CBD or the future
the question is how far will that
molyneux so there are anecdotal stories
upon blowing from Morocco Spain it's a
critical issue for certified steam
production also so we could look to make
a us a standards of the standard
or certified production a weekly
analysis pandas are
isolation zone
my problem
there is no academic research common
topic very little - there's one paper by
Ernie small versus gospel where they
took glass slides towards the trees and
trapped moment at various
from that class
and that perhaps up in the hand up you
can see that
over 10 meters
there is only 20% of the pollen range
compared to excellent at 400 meters
there is less than 1% of the pause that
is produced
what they did not do is test whether
there is sufficient moment to pollinate
that was female West because less than
1% of the series may be enough to get
falsies so what we have done here this
is a challenging experiment because of
the site were farm we went to the three
appeal the panga over there in the rain
and then planted female plants of three
different sorts
for both the ICD decoder in micro plus
one of them right next to the hanka
field or should be a pollinated and then
in the or ordinal directions at 200
meters away and at 4 or 500 meters right
to the north west and south
on the east side we could only go 200
meters for a property line
so we jumped to 1500
through our available
so we will live here the plants porcine
football
at the end of the season you will want
to buy seal by plants as the measure
functional pollination and we will also
extract cannabinoids and want to buy CD
production by plant so this will give us
sort of a dual workman's experiments we
have a lot of site information genus
pipeline
we got nine different sites
and we will also be able to verify babe
Williams data about a two to threefold
drop to be deeper
it's our first attempt I think you know
the conditions here I do state with our
topography with our moist climate of
narrative Oregon and Colorado where they
mock about ten miles movement I think
our distances will be much shorter than
the temple
a lot of
but we need
stop there enough you have to take any
questions
so the question is
the question is who is going to manage
the geographic arrangement of fiber
planting bringing fiber lamp a person
acedia
the state [ __ ] markets has already
said that they will not regulate they
are not interested in proposing or
regulated on exclusions homes to the
preference of CDT producers over
grandpa's apart
what I would suggest is that eating
plankton you get to know your neighbors
because mining is the best way to
regulate that his papers
but sometimes that's not going to work
and you
you may need to work it out through
other means
that may be
talking about rotating needles varying
distances common thinking someone not to
plant
for another field the ultimate assurance
is to move your plants indoors
sorry production
yes so the question is how much risk are
you for pollination in a hoop house for
example and there is absolutely no data
on that
I have very small
small master
are you work
so yeah if you're really screams to keep
out
I know about the people to keep out
the pathogen
so I don't what better broker who wants
to keep all active Laura mm and he
actually put HEPA filters on the answer
the phone has been extremely effective
but so he grows tomatoes and tomatoes
are really happy hundred twenty degrees
Fahrenheit so if you're trying to grow
ten-four CVD 123 degrees Fahrenheit THC
levels and I think that builders are the
only
other problems
question about isolation
it's ensues for certified
[Music]
regulators so for certified seed
production in Canada great that's
realness we have to have three levels of
isolationism psychosis or certified seed
production as one founders of the same
variety it's a motivational cultivar to
five kilometers within sight relations
between Avanti polymerization cultivar
has to be prised off perfectly
different cultivars it was the same
cultivar but of a higher pedigrees it
can be is I think it's three kilometers
isolation between those different
categories so these are every year speak
up for your summation registered
certified to the level of
other questions
turn your rotten maker pepper
yep
so the question is will with metric TCP
for all nation and after pollination so
we have not collected any sample tea
there is an active pollen production
so our intention is a whole is that some
of these microwatt will not be
pollinated by the end of the scene and
though it will be our vendor dominated
plants
oh so that so the question is could you
recover from a pill that's gone hop by
pollinating it I don't know where you at
the end of the season where you would
also get all this long
but it's a good idea on a small scale if
you've had plans that elsewhere the
more questions
question about pollination
there are no public campaign website
again they talk to growers and he'll say
you've got the ten miles away
[Music]
so it's anecdotal
I had enough hi so I've only been doing
this a year and a half I have not
encountered anyone who has told me yeah
my field dominated
I just haven't have an accountant
so there's a lot of heightened don't
know
what I had what I had to counter his
folks in Europe who said I had my deal
here my neighbor has his field over
there you can see it
they are never caught
okay
all right so Harry
[Music]
why
pianos
all that
in our
the best
but why
about all of the beads
[Music]
Industrial
in
so
you should actually
[Music]
don't
as a meet that are out there every day
pollinating your problems but there
[Music]
and we know that dirty windows
so eventually a growth in
you for our
I
[Music]
go out in field
it may not eat it
developed are benefiting from having to
be there but you throw other if you have
an outdoor alternative
[Music]
another crop this
right now in
very acceptable we could
[Music]
or why
outside
and over PA
[Music]
yeah
it doesn't have
select active on the drone
I've seen you
[Music]
but
like
a lot if they're probably countries and
also
so if we have
visit hood
we're going to be collecting all
and they're going to look at them if you
stop
the museum is trying to open drive with
other crop in
[Music]
ow
[Music]
for breakfast
[Music]
so great custom the [ __ ] is about
what happens when
particularly
you are visiting the rock collecting
pollen bringing him back to the body
on what that means
to see that we are attracting
even the
[Music]
which we did
to really live it
they're all avoiding it
so otherwise I think
[Music]
so the three votes that you're you will
become a lotta pies right
my Maker no anchors okay
it's one of ours
every acre we met you were being
probably not that there
so much the expected
small trial and justice
but it's also probably a factor
here by honeybees are bacon burger
foragers
so they might have something better
right now that they're going to do
without not always
[Applause]
all right we are in the whole gang so if
anyone does not have a handout Larry and
then give you one it was like all the
others more or less
I was really looking forward to having
folks up at our CBD trial this morning
because you know when I started this a
couple of years ago
[Music]
you know there are places for next love
to grow and there are places that have
been really unhappy so where we have one
of our cvd variety styles but look at
the back of the sheet and you can see
the list of writings the varieties that
were planted where it started in the
greenhouse we wanted to ensure and
where's my and blended into the fuel and
they were still early July July 6 in
honor
indica trial and July 9th in Geneva
so in those are plants that we were just
at the end of the very dry period so we
had there are late fit with drip
irrigation and lactation and we were
irrigating now and then it started to
rain
there is a wee bit lower than the other
end so the water rain that way and the
plants that have wet feet for an
extended period of time even though they
were on raised beds
some of them light outside some of them
are extremely stunted and if you go down
the field when you get that slight
decline the plants at the end and that
was just a bit drier are doing might
well so I think it's really important to
know that it's not always the case the
reason that we're doing the trial is to
answer some of the questions that many
of you have asked in terms of you know
what what impact CBD left and what
impacts THC levels here in the state of
New York if you're growing for CBD you
don't want your plant specific above
that 0.3% be level and
you know we have information from
Colorado and Oregon in Kentucky but we
don't have information on the stresses
in New York for example the plants that
have now had wet feet for as much of
their lives in the fields are they going
to have a higher THC or CBD content
because of that flood stress and and we
don't know so to compare we actually are
growing the ultra-rich bees at seven all
turrets dried from Nevada we're going
those in our greenhouse and what we want
to do is compare that you as well as the
CBD and
d level of the greenhouse from plants to
those plants that were grown in the
field and for this year I will compare
the indica trial such an even drop and
the greenhouse plants and I saw some
pictures as Damian things show that the
length of the field in a plant
architecture it's one of the things that
were looking at in these varieties so
ineffective rain and winds down in the
HIPPA control that last week some of the
plants actually snacks you have the stem
wood lips not strong enough to handle
the foliage and the plant architecture
that was about
so what we're measuring on all of these
plants right now we are measuring
establishment if they die we're
rendering plant architecture we're doing
that by counting the number of stones
where leaves would come out of plant and
then the number of notes that have
branches so that gives you an idea of
how branching eclectus for some people
they're looking for a big branching
plant that looks more like a Christmas
tree and for other folks they won't be a
single peg and so we want to be able to
provide you with in New York in our
thick layers
what is the plan middle of life
naturally the goal with this so we'll
have a plant architecture for top height
and in the greenhouse what are what are
called plants now
[Music]
[Music]
so so we have light as well as
architecture and then we'll have to not
only see levels but we hope to have the
whole panel so that we can give you an
idea of what is being produced under
conditions conditions but we have our
process as we move forward we hope that
people to come here next year we hope to
have some plans in I tunnels right now
our plants are high tunnels are in a
place that gets rather wet so we'll have
to be modified but it'd be great to be
able to give us information on final
production for the pre-health corruption
versus feel for us and that's what we
really hope we get to do
new cultivars come along new genetics in
plants we must be able to test athletics
and one of the things you really want to
be able to do with experiments like this
sista test rapidly so we you know sort
of on the fly understand how stressed
conditions are modifying to secondary
metabolites or CBD in the plants so one
of the things that my life is doing
along those same lines that we're
looking at SESC EPS microbial so you
heard of the human microbiome of
microbes others again and in our stomach
and that affects many many attributes of
our health the same exact thing is true
in
and one of my students of HB Sigonella
gala instead look last year at the
microbial of hemp plant and she's now
identified sort of the microbes that are
on and you know in she looked at six
different locations for awhile
but bacteria and fungi are Hotlanta
these aren't necessarily pests
they're just present and and interacting
with the planet it's none of her other
systems that the microbes on the plants
and modified things like drought
tolerance flowering time and secondary
metabolism which with food modify our
THC or CBD levels so we really want to
know what's there
additionally if there are beneficial
microbes that are being you know they're
associated with the roots of plants if
we can identify some of those and we can
work without Taylor who is an expert at
using things like that to actually
enhance plant grow some of the things
that we're working on one one thing that
Ali found that I thought was absolutely
fascinating was that in them and the
microbes that are found on the flower of
the template plant the most common
microbes are those microbes that are
have previously been reported from
extreme environments like hot springs
I saw and so there's something you know
the secondary metabolites in the flower
of the plants that the microbes that
associate there are zones that can
handle extreme environments and so
that's something that Pope you would be
into as well right for sure summertime
or noting that in the greenhouse and in
the field and steel plants have flower
earlier than the green HealthQuest
[Music]
diets monthly
we do have one but it wasn't planted
after the field
everything works
so the gardens and our own flower
committee we have four of them are
cauliflower
but we have we have both larger lines
that still have not allowed so we have
both males and females in the population
and as soon as we see a male we cut that
out and there are females varieties that
come from places that when wet
great question in the future what we do
we drive right there cultivars we can
handle more rain and if we can find out
that salutely what I think that is going
to be one of the things that our
breeding program our breeding program
that is led by dr. smart well we'll look
at a lot with the flowering time as a
license so we do have part of the
lighting in the greenhouse but it is not
longer than the daily
right right so that's one of the things
that we hope to get out of our high
tunnel experiments next year is you know
can we manage moisture via high tunnel
and how does that compare to greenhouse
truck
yeah so the question is did the dry
period at the beginning the year of
excess dress and the plants talking to
the flower earlier compared to those in
the greenhouse and I think
the dry at the beginning following five
furlongs weapon that is addressed
that part
[Music]
our farmer living plants right so how do
we decide when departments and agree
with dike when it's 20 days before our
harvester you can I
yeah probably going to do that how are
you
certainly we need to hire and that will
be taken into account and my guess is
that we'll probably depending on the
weather sake sometime between mid to end
of September and then 20
right great questions that I've been
about plant architecture insight and how
that we take it into account and improve
event might happen and it will feed or
not to in any and it's proving at all
there are some
but we're not doing anything on it for
this particular time
so in future trial
music I'll be doing burnings make loans
and for my part of the experiments I
won't be doing to make clothes out of
the litter if you have documents so the
issue is
the material transfer agreement number
would you
so if we are restricted
cultivating and propagating
we'll probably try to do
for breeding applause
[Applause]
mention one project that were worth
which is too
I'm sure many of you have seen the
problems
haven't
five those of biosigns
[Music]
company based in portal that will
analyze the DNA
earth with everything else
[Music]
some very cool and what happened
talk bars related to one another in
Connecticut
23 and here
by-laws PHY lol
a very cool interface
zooming through the pile of galaxies
so we are trying to do the same thing
for the CPE tell the hearts that folks
are going to do
I have already collected
small examples
for us question is
are those through the Titans
under assertive
verify the table
I was elated earlier one another
on the street
so I know there are number throwers
for example
the public and here is
hi
today or
with the property brothers
different
ha
okay I think that brings the formal
presentations to a conclusion
I'm really sorry if you can't make it
out from the deal but I would like
open it up and give folks an opportunity
you need to take off you can take off
but if you have
let's open it up for a general question
and answers
[Music]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu